خلال مقابله في احدى البرامج المذاعه على
فضائيه ام بي سي مصر 2 دعي المصري اسامه
قابيل الى ادخال الفرحه في قلوب النساء
قائلا كل سيده تفرحها حتاخد عليها اجر
الداعيه الاسلامي الذي يحث على جبر
الخواطر يعني لو فرحت زوجتك او خالتك او
عمتك او امك حتاخد اجر وثواب وكمان لو
فرحت زميلتك في الشغل هتاخد اجر وثواب
يعني لو عندك زميله جديده لسه بتتعلم
والشغل الشغل وانت علمتها وفهمتها بدل ما
تنكد عليها
وبقت كويسه وفرحت بده حتاخذ اجر وثواب
تفاعلا
على تواصل الاجتماعي في مصر ولاقت
استحسانا خاصه من قبل النساء ومن قبل انا
ايضا تمام
مامتك اختك
بنتك وخلينا واسع الدايره عشان النهارده
23 زميلتك في الشغل مش ممكن تكون انت
مديرها او ممكن نكون احنا في تيم ورك مع
بعض فاحنا فريق واحد ممكن تلاقي واحد يعني
انا اسف يبص
بنظره مختلفه مثلا او يقول لها لا التاسك
دي انا اللي هاخدها المهمه دي بتاعتي انا
طب ما تدي لها خليها تعمل ترينينج وتدرب
اه تفرحها تجبر بخاطرها تدخل تساعدها تقول
لها الله على فكره الموضوع ده انت عملتيه
كويس جدا واعتقد المره الجايه لو انت عملت
بلس بالطريقه المعينه وضفتي هتبقى حاجه
جميله جدا سيدنا النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
يقول من صرح انثى كان كمنبكه من خشيه الله
سال الناس في مصر مشاهدينا من المسؤول عن
سعاده المراه لنرى الاجابه
انا شايفه ان الحاجه الاساسيه اللي بتسعد
المراه لو في حب حقيقي في حياتها والحاجه
الثانيه بقى الاكل دي اهم حاجه طول ما هي
حاسه بالامان هي مرضيه وهي دي ساعدتها
يعني النجاح ممكن بيطور منها ويخليها
سعيده وراقي وسط المجتمع شايفه الاول
المسؤول عن سعاده المراه هي الفلوس هي
بتقدر تشتري اي حاجه هي عايزاها عامه
والقناعه
تقنع باي
ظروف هي موضوع فيها وترضى والرضا يعني اي
حد يجيب لها شيكولاته تبقى مبسوطه جدا
يعني فدي سر سعاده المراه في الشيكولاته
يعني ممكن اسعد نفسي مفيش حاجه معينه يعني
ممكن انزل اخرج نفسي اروح اماكن انا ما
رحتهاش
اكل الاكل اللي انا بحبه
من القاهره ينضم الينا داعي الاسلامي
الدكتور اسامه قابيل دكتور صباح الخير
صباح الخير يا دكتور ولا فضه فوق
الفرح والنور والسعاده علينا كلنا يا رب
دكتور طالما احنا في 2023 وانا حمسك في
نقطه انه زميلتك لو ساعدتها حتفرحها
واذا اجرو ثواب طب لو اتجوزتها هيكون ايه
طيب خليني اقول لحضرتك في البدايه بسم
الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحقيقه في عباده جميله جدا اسمها عباده
السعاده والفرح وادخال السرور على قلوب
الناس فالحقيقه كل يوم اتنين عندنا فقره
دينيه اجتماعيه في قناه ام بي سي مصر
بنحاول ان احنا نتكلم عن الجوانب
الاجتماعيه وازاي نفرح الناس وازاي نبين
جوانب الاطمئنان والسعاده في ديننا
الاسلام الحنيف فالحقيقه كانت الحلقه اللي
فاتت عن عباده الفرح والسعاده
فحبينا نتكلم عن مفهوم الفرح والسعاده
وجبنه حديث سيدنا النبي صلى الله عليه
حضرتي واله افضل الاعمال واحب الاعمال الى
الله تبارك وتعالى سرور
تدخله على مسلم وكمان سيدنا النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم علمنا يعني احب الاعمال
الله تبارك وتعالى ان يكون الانسان في عون
اخيه الانسان فالحقيقه وسعنا دائره الفهم
وخصوصا النهارده احنا في 23 فع نقول لكل
الناس كل الشركات
الاجنبيه وشركات الخاصه والوظائف العامه
وكل المؤسسات بتجمع ما بين الرجال والاناث
فبتلاقي بعض المعاملات الغير مقبوله او
السلبيه فحبينا نظهر المعنى ده علشان خاطر
نقول للناس ازاي نفرح ونسعد بعضينا طب ما
نتجوز يعني
طبعا
الجواز يخدع حضرتك بين الايجاب والقبول
والله لو احنا بنشتغل في مؤسسه وحصل فيه
الفه او حصل فيه كيمياء بين اي زميل
وزميله ويتجوزوا ما فيش مشكله
زميلته هو راح يتعس زوج
مزح مزح لا احنا بنتكلم وبنوسع ههه انا
كنت سعيده جدا بصراحه
بتصريحاتك وبتمنى انه يعني الجميع يلتزم
بها مش بس رجل باتجاه المراه ولكن المراه
ايضا تجاه الرجل طيب عشان نكون منصفين
دكتور هل
انتارس لحضراتكم بما انه
يعني كما يقال الاقربون اولى بالمعروف بدل
قبل ما نسعد زميلتنا خل نسعد زوجتنا
صح نعم هل تمارس هذا الموضوع معي في
الحديث دكتور نعم نعم سيدنا النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم علمنا كلنا خيركم خيركم
لاهله وانا خيركم لاهلي فالانسان يبقى
عنده افضليه وخيريه واحسان وحسن معامله
لان سيدنا النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم علمنا
كده ما اكرمهن الا كريم وما اهانهن الا
ليل ولكن احنا بنتكلم النهارده عن مفهوم
اداب واخلاقيات العمل النهارده المجتمعات
العربيه كلها في مصر والمملكه العربيه
السعوديه والامارات العربيه المتحده وكل
المجتمعات العربيه بتنادي بوضع افضل
للمراه ومعامله افضل وتمكين المراه في
الوظائف الاكاديميه والتعليميه والطبيه
والصحيه والاعلاميه وغيرها من الاماكن
اللي علشان ده كان موجود على عهد سيدنا
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم في مشاركه في
تعاون وانا يمكن عملت فوكس وعملت سبوت كده
وتحديد على فكره الموظفه او الزميله اللي
لسه جايه جديد
الابتسامه ما بين الناس صدقه اذا كان كذلك
لكن هي فقط المراه ولا المراه ايضا يجب ان
تسعد زوجها اخيها ابنها زميلها في العمل
بص يا حبيبي المعامله بين الرجل والمراه
تخضع لادخال الفرحه والسرور كلنا بنحاول
نسعد بعض وخليني اقول لحضرتك بصراحه كل
يوم زي الصباح الجميل اللي احنا فيه ده كل
يوم في اضافات جديده واعمال وعطاءات كتير
كتير قوي بتبقى في العالم كله فلو في
مشاركه وتعاون بين كل فريق عمل سواء كان
في الاسره جوه البيت بين الزوج والزوجه
بين الرجل وامراته وبين الاخ واخته وبين
الزميل والزميله في الشغل كلنا فريق واحد
ربنا يقول في القران وتعاونوا على البر
والتقدير ويمكن انا تطرقت في الكلام في في
فقره ام بي سي ان التعاون على البر
والتقوى ويكون بين الرجل والمراه وفي كل
مكان واحنا عايشين في الدنيا علشان كلنا
نحاول نسعد بعضنا من الناحيه الحياه
فعلينا ان نستجيب لامر الله ودائما بحب
اؤكد واقول لكل الناس حياتنا ملهاش اعاده
فلازم نعيشها بسعاده نعيش العمر مره
والنور
ان شاء الله يكون يعني تكون هذه الرساله
وصلت للجميع رجالا ونساء
ضد الرجال راويه ما ادري
والله
زميلتي انا ليس سالتك عن زميلتي دائما
تجرح
مشاعرية ربنا يبارك فيك ربنا يخليك
شكرا ربنا يوفقكم ان شاء الله وتقدموا
رساله جميله شكرا جزيلا
الداعي الاسلاميه يعطيك الف عافيه
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات